So one of the brilliant things
designers do is produce designs.
They can also help you with one
of the other more important parts
of the process,
which is choosing between those designs.
So, Jonathan,
what are some best practices for
making decisions between
designs using user feedback?
>> Sure, I like to think of it as three
sort of different general areas of your
designs, when you're thinking about how
to structure your app or your website.
So we have information architecture,
which is sort of the way that things are
structured, and the sort of the flow.
There's also interaction design,
which is whether or
not it's easy to find a button
on your page or your app.
And then there's also the design
element or the visual design.
The visual design allows a user
to give feedback on the appeal,
or the color scheme, or
other elements within your design.
So thinking a bit within
these three general areas
gives you sort of the ability to sort
of ask the questions that you want to
get good feedback from your design.
<< Okay, so as an example we had
feedback in our original paper prototype
that our structure was confusing, you
just couldn't actually check things off
in that from information architecture.
And then we also had feedback that the
frequent action button was good size,
and so
that would be like interaction design.
>> Exactly.
>> And
then we also had feedback that our
check boxes were hard to find, or
not visually appealing.
And so that would be visual design.
>> Correct.
Yeah.
All those elements combined
together I think are essentially
the concept or
some experts call the conceptual design.
But all those aspects are fundamental
to the design of your app.
And you want to be thinking about all
three as you are developing your app.
>> Okay.
So let's say we've got
a designer who's given us
two different visual designs for
an element.
Let's say they've given us a button
that is designed one way and
a button that is designed another way.
How would we go about using user
research to choose between those?
>> Sure.
So you can do two types of studies.
One, you can run through
a group of users, like two or
three users where you show button A then
you show button B and you ask for
them to provide feedback on that set.
Then in a separate study,
you can do it for
a separate group of users
showing button D, then button A.
You can compare your notes from both
of those studies to find out which
is the best button to use.
>> And do users tend to prefer
the one they see first generally, or
the one they see last generally?
Or is it not as clear as all that?
>> It's not always that clear and
simple.
Oftentimes you want to get
a user's initial reactions.
But showing them close together
really helps give them
a visual cue to telling you whether or
not it's something they really enjoy.
>> Okay.
One of the things we just used
as an example was there's button
A and there's button B.
What happens if the designer gives
you five or ten button designs?
Do you still test all of those at once
or do you test just two at a time?
>> Yeah, that's a great question.
I think it's really important to be
thinking about can the user achieve
what you're intending them
to achieve with your design.
So, it can be ten buttons or
it can be 15 buttons, but
can they achieve what the intended task
or objective is with your designs?
So, if the designer presents you
with many different buttons,
it may be helpful just to kind
of trim it down a little bit.
But, if you have that many buttons in
order to achieve the intended task,
you may still need to test on all of
those buttons being available there.
>> So it sounds like it's best to
compare these buttons
in separate studies.
It also sounds likes it's best to think
about all three levels of design,
when you're thinking about
alternate designs for your app.
>> Yeah.
That's right.
And I think you sort of hit
the nail on the head when you say,
thinking about all three levels.
Thinking about all three levels
really encompasses the heart or
the concept or the conceptual
design aspect of your app.
You should really be doing something
that enables a user to do
something that they love to do.
And that's really the heart
aspect of your app.
Something that I always really
enjoy talking about too.
>> Awesome,
thank you again for coming in.
I appreciate it.
>> Thank you.